[Music]
all right your new book it is out this
week it is sitting right in front of me
heavens on earth the scientific search
for the afterlife immortality and utopia
well did you figure it out is there a I
have the answer got the answer is there
any scientific evidence for any of those
things Michael Shermer toyou know I'm
sorry to say that there's not there's
actually some good news at the end of
the book but I do address all of the
different versions of the afterlife
heaven I go through the monotheism
Judaism Christianity and Islam of course
and right off the bat you see there's a
huge body of literature in those areas
of the history of heaven and the fact
that history that heaven has a history
and now I'm a historian of science so
like cosmology has a history the history
of cosmology how did how did we figure
out how big the universe is and all that
stuff but there there's kind of a sense
of progress like we're getting ever
closer to understanding what's actually
out there with these history of Heaven
literature there's no sense of progress
at all it's like well this group used to
believe that and then they encounter the
Egyptians and then they change it to
this and then then they the Babylonian
captivity and that the ink of the Jews
inculcated their worldview and there's
no sense like oh well there's something
out there and we're getting closer to it
not at all
so that was kind of interesting and also
how they change depending did that
surprise you because they are just
hearing I mean I kind of knew that thank
you yeah no I mean that wasn't a big
thing it was just sort of an interesting
observation and then do also have to
deal with the non monotheism's you know
what it's called the eastern wisdom
traditions Buddhism Hinduism Taoism
soive old chapter on that I went to
Deepak Chopra Center down in Carlsbad
and got into the whole meditation and
yoga and chanting and the tea and the
incense and they're like okay Deepak
let's talk about this and so he gave me
the whole thing so I really that was
kind of my Avenue into talking about
consciousness and you know their view
the Buddhist view is there's no life and
death in the sense there's a beginning
an end like in Western culture we have
this idea of a linear linear time
there's a beginning and an end
big bang that you know and so forth but
in in in this world view you know the
physical universe including us we're
just visit just temporary physical
instantiation of consciousness
consciousness is pervasive it is well
okay
detox language the ground of all being
you know the ontological primitive okay
so he says these things and it takes me
you know page what do you mean by the
ontological primitive and part of the
problem is that is a Western scientists
you know we use words in a certain way
that and they don't and they use words
in a different way so we're off to just
talking cross purposes there so much of
my conversations with Deepak have been
just stop tell me what you mean by this
word because else we have our words you
know I can't read your thoughts so
anyway but the core of the book really
is scientific attempts okay I call this
the afterlife or atheists you know these
are all the the people that are don't
necessarily think that that that there's
a heaven in fact they're pretty sure
there isn't anything like a traditional
heaven because there's no evidence for
that so but interestingly in in surveys
I was looking up about a third of
atheists think that there might be an
afterlife okay so they say they I don't
believe in God but there might be
something now what are they talking
about well you're a star wars fan you
know something like the force right you
know there's something out there that
you continue on and you know and some of
them do find that kind of Deepak
worldview that sort of Buddhist you know
Buddhism has quite a resurgence now
there's a number of books you know Bob
Wright's book Buddhism is true and so on
what do you mean it's true okay that's a
that's a big statement the truth
statement okay well okay so they think
when you die you just go back to where
you were before you were born is I open
the book saying what when people say
where do you think you go when you die
Shermer I sit the same place I was
before I was born
what are you talking about you weren't
anywhere right well did a Buddhist you
you actually are returning to where you
were because consciousness is just
always there's no beginning area and
it's just always was and is and
everywhere okay that's really hard for
us to grasp
what they what the the scientist group
these communities I delve into the cry
on assist the transhumanists the extra
pians there against entropy good luck
with that and they're against and
yeah you know that's a theory well just
you know let's they start off simple
enough which seems obvious you know diet
nutrition exercise you know be healthy
and so on in a way all of life is
pushing back against entropy this is
most of what we do is a push back
against entropy you know we have you
know house we have a ceiling to protect
us from the weather that's fighting
entropy basically nature just wants to
kill us all all the time that's
basically what it does and so natural
selection selected those that were able
to push back against it but ultimately
you can't defeat it right so but this is
you know they so you start off it's a
transhumanist sixth rope and they're all
in the same category like the soul is
your genome and your connectome the
pattern of all your information all of
the stuff that your body is made out of
gets recycled about every decade or so
your skin cells blood cells it's it's
all none of the material almost it is
the original from ten years ago even
much less when you were born so you're
not the Dave Rubin you were a decade ago
I know your friends tell you that you've
changed a lot so when we say well
there's a there's a unit there called
Dave Rubin who's a person and Anna self
who has a sense of self and I have a
sense of who you are that's not the
material that's the pattern of
information that's in your memories and
your genome and so on that gets the keep
that keeps it going okay so their idea
the singularity people the mind
uploading and so somehow you got to keep
that going alright so it starts super
basic diet and exercise just kind of
keep the body going but no one's ever
gone above the ceiling upper ceiling of
about 120 125 now so first of all one of
the myths I debunk is this idea that
people live twice as long as they used
to know more and more people are getting
up to the upper ceiling thanks to public
health measures and vaccinations and
things like that but it's not like no
one 100 years ago or 200 years ago live
to be in their 80s or 90s
lots of people did just not as many as
do today so to get that the upper
ceiling there is blocked by a bunch of
different systems that all fall apart at
the same time around a in your 80s or so
you know just the telomeres at the end
of your chromosomes that break off every
time a cell divides they can only do
that so many times it's called the
hayflick number
so one of the goals of the science of
aging is to somehow figure that out well
there's lots of claims about well if you
eat this supplement every day you're
telomers will be better yeah
acai berries yeah yeah red wine actually
sleep apparently is really good for
keeping your telomers more in place it
doesn't allow your cells to divide more
but but that they they don't die quiet
as quickly okay again these are all
measures to just get more and more of us
up to the upper ceiling the only way to
break through there would be a complete
genetic reengineering of the genome to
stop that from happening without because
there's a there's a name for cells that
divide indefinitely
it's called cancer yeah alright so
without turning people into cancer is
blobs you know and that's just one of
you know dozens of systems that all fall
apart so this we're not even close to
the science of like figuring that out
and breaking through but when you hear
this and then you hear about who's the
Google guy I'm blanking on his name
suddenly that's doing the singularity
yeah Ray Kurzweil yeah when you hear it
like he's taking like what it like some
infinite number pills supplements a day
yeah what is it
supplement 5757 today do those he's
trying to to break that time that's
right absolutely totally ya know so
their program okay so every aging expert
I've talked to they have world's leading
this is all [ __ ] it's not gonna
happen
not without program you'd have to so
maybe a CRISPR a future CRISPR
technology where you actually reprogram
the genome to stop the telomeres for
breaking off so frequently and the cell
then divine without creating cancer okay
that's a huge problem but that's just
one of many you know Aubrey de Grey any
documentary you've ever seen on aging
and longevity and immortality you've
seen him he's got long red hair a long
both ooh Scylla a beard he loves beer he
has he's British that these British guys
he's a great British accent and you know
the first person to live a thousand
years is alive today and you know he's
got a whole program sends Sen s this is
basically these seven things you got to
do to reprogram yourselves okay so you
can you could read about it look him up
it's great stuff but okay and and and he
likes beer and beers on the lit list so
that's good
coincidence but ultimately know that
none of this is going to work now the
Kurzweil program is it goes beyond that
okay even if we don't succeed you can
you can have yourself chronically frozen
and maybe a thousand years from now okay
well first of all you're being frozen on
the worst day of your life the day
you're dying the state treats cryonics
is a form of burial right so you can't
like prep yourself with the antifreeze
stuff or all that because they'll kill
you and then that would be murder so you
actually have to just let her let things
take their course and you're dead then
the team rushes in and packed you a nice
and ships you off to
Alcor one of these places and they pump
you full of this antifreeze stuff to try
to prevent the freezing from destroying
your cells anyway it doesn't work
because a like a human brain is it's
huge compared to an embryo so you can
freeze an embryo and bring it back
IVF it works not brains they're too big
and so so far everybody frozen today
they're never being brought back it's
not going to happen
Disney frozen or nothing no no that was
that's just not even true the day he
died was the day that I think it was Al
Khor one of them opened their doors and
there was the two complaining press
releases Ted Williams though is
apparently his head is frozen that Al
Gore apparently that is true yeah and
the first person ever frozen was a
Glendale college psychology professor
where I went as a student no he was
already dead and frozen by the time I
got there but I thought well that's a
weird thing yeah
now so here's the other problem with
Kurzweil is idea okay so in the meantime
if we could copy your connectome again
this it's it's you are represented by
your memories all your pattern of
information in there put it in a
computer just scan every synaptic
connection and put it in a giant compute
ok so first of all we're not even
remotely close to having a big enough
computer dolt even one brain much less a
hundred brains of the elite or
everybody's brain but even so let's say
Moore's law you know carry it out a
hundred years from now the problem here
is the problem of identity who are you
so let's say we we scan your brain and
put it in the computer at what age you
know when you're 29 they're 30 you know
because that's supposedly the ideal age
cuz that's when Jesus died right because
in Christianity there's a debate about
when you wake up in heaven with Jesus
there and so on who's there
is are you physically there you know
some of them say yeah you're physically
there
how old yeah well
okay 30 30 okay nobody wants to get to
heaven as the 95 I guess not but but if
you think about that well then what
about all the memories I've had since I
was thirty because I've had 33 of them
33 years of memories that they'd be lost
I that would be tragic and but but it's
okay know you can have the memories of
your total life
yeah but the memories now I'm 63 now the
memories of when I was 40 now are very
different from the memories when I was
40 when that was happening yeah whatever
it was my interpretation of that now is
different everything is different so
even scanning every memory isn't really
capturing you as is a harder problem
that would be and and then there's also
the point of view problem like when you
go to sleep tonight you wake up tomorrow
morning you're a little groggy but
consciousness comes back and you're
looking at the world through your eyes
so it called this the point of view self
instead of the memory self so the point
of view self is there's a continuity of
consciousness and and perspective now
you go under general anesthesia you wake
up little groggy or five hours later and
it comes back if you are copied and put
in a computer then they turn it on like
Johnny Depp and transcendence he's in
the computer looking out through the
little camera you know and there's this
girlfriend with the guy who what yeah
you're doing what and yeah no no that's
not gonna happen because your point of
view isn't going to transfer from your
body into the computer because let's say
we did this to a fancy fMRI brain
scanner and we did this while you're
standing there you just like we slide
you in scan your brain we get every
single synaptic connection put it in the
computer turn it on
and you're still standing there next to
the machine you all of a sudden don't go
into there your point of view you're
still standing there going eight no I'm
Dave over here and then the computers
going no I'm Dave it's just a copy right
and no twin ever looks at their sibling
and go well there I am yeah no no no not
now
so the Kurzweil is of the world will say
yes there's there could be 10 Dave
Reubens but each of them thinks they're
the real day of Reuben but of course the
moment you diverge and have different
life experiences you just go left and
the other one goes right out of the room
and all of a sudden life becomes
different you're gonna have different
memories in different connections and so
who's the real you okay so it's really a
problem a philosophy
these guys have you're not gonna wake up
in the computer it's just a copy so
where are you yeah and religions kind of
have the same problem you know you're
dead in the grave and what Jesus takes
you up there well what's going up there
well the soul what does that means
pattern information at what age they
have the same set of logical problems
because it for Jew for Jews in
particular the body is still in the
grave and many Christian sects say you
know your body is not resurrected it's
just your soul the body says yeah but
the your memories are in there in the
grave
no no they get taken up there how does
this happen you know God works in
mysterious well gate boom man I just
watched I just watched the matrix for
like the thousandth time there's a lot
of matrix ways I can go with this but
I'll try to
I'll try to keep it a little more narrow
for this so is there an inherent problem
discussing all this that you're trying
to look at something through a
scientific lens that the people who are
the believers simply don't look through
that lens so you're never gonna get to
uh I guess this is the struggle of the
skeptic all times right you're it's hard
to get to somebody to break through to
somebody that is going off a different
set of premises to start yes okay that's
it that is a problem right so but my
book is a work of science and the
primary focus is you know not not only
that I'm skeptical of religious versions
of the afterlife but all these
scientific attempts they're not going to
succeed therefore what we do now is all
the more important our lives our loves
our connections and all that so I end
with a you know a really uplifting
chapter but ultimately yes I do think in
the chapter on Deepak I talked about
this problem of language you know the
see in the world through a scientific
perspective is very it's not in the
majority position most people are
duelists they're Paul bloom calls them
calls us natural-born duelists and in
his lab with children he shows that like
if it'll two-year-old you know here's a
mouse and it gets munched by the
alligator now the mouse is dead you know
what where is the mouse oh the mouse is
off in this other place and he misses
his mommy and he's hungry and from a
very early age we have the sense that
something continues on mm-hmm
so I actually opened the book by talking
about this problem of imagine you're
dead you know most people say well I see
my body in the casket
my friends and family are there and
hopefully they're mourning but of course
you wouldn't see anything because you
know to be conscious of anything you
have to be alive and so you know imagine
you can't imagine anything it's it's a
it's like imagine there's no universe
not not just no planets stars and
galaxies no space-time no light nothing
you can't you can't actually imagine
that in the in so here we we bump up
against the epistemological wall and the
language wall like Vic and Stein talked
about this you know these words we use
they get reified into things even the
word nothing it's no thing it's a thing
that doesn't exist
well when you're dead it's not like
you're going to this place called
nothing no you see all of a sudden we
just hit this word like if there's no
universe there's nothing as if nothing
is a thing it's not even that so the
that you ended this book on a positive
note I guess by arguing that there's no
scientific basis for an afterlife or a
utopia or whatever else you're really
putting the onus I think this is what
you were just saying sort of you're
putting the onus on us right this moment
absolutely yeah which is scary for a lot
of people well I think it's it should be
uplifting it's like because instead of
thinking well either I don't matter or
none of this really matters I'm just
waiting for the next stage or the next
play the next act in the play and this
proscenium drama were in here it's just
a temporary thing you're gonna miss out
on something now look I don't know that
there's no afterlife nobody does for
sure
so whether there's an afterlife or not
this is the life we live in right here
right now I call this
alvey's error so in Annie Hall is a
flashback scene where you know Woody
Allen plays Alvy Singer yeah and he's
eight years old or whatever and he won't
do his homework and his mother takes him
to the psychiatrist
Alvie why won't you do your homework the
universe is expanding the universe is
expanding yeah the universe is expanding
and eventually it's all gonna blow up so
none of this matters and his mother
yells at him we live it Brooklyn
Brooklyn's not expanding you got to do
your homework well that's kind of my
message you know we live in Brooklyn
we don't live 15 billion years from now
the heat death in the universe nothing
matters we don't live in heaven with
Jesus now none of that actually matters
now yeah what matters is now and the
people you're in the
room with the society you live in the
people you engage with and so all of
those things matter more than ever once
you think about it and put them in big
perspective whatever your beliefs are in
the afterlife when you will around all
these different groups of people whether
they were Jewish a Christian or Hindu or
Buddhist or whatever it is even if none
of it could be proven one way or another
and none of the science was there
backing up anything they said did you
sense that any group of them had a
better handle on this
I think Jews I think Jews are a little
more realistic about I mean the original
idea of the afterlife for Jews was it
was nothing it's like you just we don't
go anywhere now modern Jews that they do
believe in an afterlife nothing quite as
extreme like Christians have a whole
elaborate idea of what it's going to be
like and the Left Behind and all that
stuff
I think Jews are more realistic
particularly that their focus on rituals
now family community taking care of one
another
and so the Christian sects that do that
I admire more and respect more though
the Christian groups that want to help
the poor now man the soup kitchens care
about people that are suffering as
opposed to those that are fanatically
obsessed with you know say they
afterlife or evangelizing converting
people there is this kind of split in
Christianity on you know that it's kind
of a political split you know liberal
Christians tend to be more like our duty
is now and Jesus wants us to help poor
people and you know and so there for
women's rights and you know the rights
of minorities and so on and the others
that tend to be more conservative sort
of Christians sort of that started
starting the 80s with the moral majority
we're not worried about those people our
job is to get our guy into the White
House and then we can influence the the
elections and legislation with our
beliefs yeah he was big on the rich yeah
wait when did that happen when did Jesus
become a conservative anyway so I think
you asked you know what if I think those
the idea of that the here and now and
taking care of people making a world a
better place that's where it's at yeah
the Utopia one is interesting to me
because first off did you get a sense
that across the board when people say
utopia they
the same thing what do they mean by
utopia do they mean just this endless
place of pleasures and attack Euler one
yeah what do they actually mean by
utopia
well people mean different things by it
but but you know I cover that from the
commune's 19th century American communes
which are relatively harmless you know
people think people weren't murdered
they didn't commit mass suicide they had
a lot of free sex so you know how bad
could it be not very successful they
didn't last long - the kind of utopian
cults like the Heaven's Gate or the
Jonestown where they that does get a
little riskier like like we're gonna
sacrifice ourselves and go to the other
side where it's even better I mean
Jones's final speech he's talking about
this you know sort of utopian communist
state that we're all going to in this
next world but really communist the ax
marks if you look at Marxism there's a
book about this on comparisons of
Christianity and Marxism you know there
was a glorious paradisaical state before
the fall and that's when there was no
property no private property everybody
had an equal share everybody did their
equal share of work and then there was
the fall you know like the fall was that
he went right well they think of this
you know they in Paleolithic times
prehistoric prehistoric they you know
they they had this idea this is the way
it was like now it's true
hunter-gatherers are more egalitarian
than we are but but they're far from any
kind of idealistic communist state any
case that's at a certain set problems
but they certainly did much worse you
know more violence more tribalism more
rape and pillage in and say yeah of
course but this is Marxist idea and then
the fall which private property
capitalism comes on ruins everything and
then we have our second coming you know
capitalism will eventually collapse on
its own but we can kind of help it along
you know and and then when it collapses
communism will return you know so it's a
very prelapsarian and then the fall and
then the return to the Golden Age it's a
it's an old idea you know that comes up
often and it's we have a big enough
brain to imagine what life could be like
and it could be better than now yes
absolutely so therefore we should aim
for this you know perfect state you know
and so I talk about why does this fail
they always fail and the problem is is
this human nature is too variable
there's too many different interests and
talents and skills and
whatever that there is the question
what's the right Society there is no
answer because there isn't one right
Society so the flaw is us right I mean
this is you're talking about a lot
lately we can't make a perfect system
because we are not perfect right and and
even you know even saying it that way I
would say we're just so variable there's
multiple well I like Sam's metaphor
multiple Peaks on the moral landscape
there isn't one right answer there's
multiple answers now there's a bunch of
wrong answers and some Peaks are higher
than others yeah so but but like say
what's the right democracy you know
should we have an electoral college or
not should we have a progressive tax
regressive tax or flat tax I'm not sure
there's a right answer to those you
might say well for us this is what we
want to do because this is what we like
it's like the you know the private
community that says no doors can be
painted red in this neighborhood period
and you can't paint your house pink
either you know you know these
Association rules okay but this
association over here you know there's
sort of the hippie community you want
you can paint your door any color you
want and in fact the more colors the
better okay so in a free market you just
let this kind of happen so the problem
with a top-down by Fiat these are the
rules because this is the right way to
live that will always fail because there
is no right way to live so it's
interesting I mean your book is about
belief and science of that but you're
making great arguments really again for
things that I know you believe in
otherwise like the individual animated
state power and the control and you
owning your life and being pretty well I
think there's I think there's evidence
and reason for those positions as being
correct but you know that we are the
individual is the fundamental unit of a
political nature because it's the
individual who can suffer it's the
individual brain that experiences pain
and suffering not the collective you
know races don't vote individual members
of a race vote you know so again we have
to get out of this problem we've talked
about identity politics I don't want to
be a a white guy that's how you treat me
I'm just an indium ichael trimmer you're
Dave Rubin we're different the
individual is what counts and and we
know from experiments over say the last
three or four centuries in governance
some
work better than others now again it
could be that you know a progressive tax
is slightly better than a regressive tax
okay you can debate that but a
totalitarian state is is objectively
measurably worse than a democratic state
you only have to ask yourself would you
rather live in North Korea or South
Korea would you rather have lived in
West Germany or East Germany yeah and so
on you just pick these that these aren't
controlled experiments they're natural
experiments that happen anyway
everything then study them after that
that's science right that's what
scientists do most of science is not
done with controlled experiments it's
done with the comparative method most
social science what has already happened
okay so these these states have these
gun control laws these have these
different gun control laws as comparison
to parent now it's messy you know that
you get in these correlational studies
that are very complicated but still it's
a method that can get us there I think
yeah it's sort of like well would you
rather live in Venezuela right now or
right I now see every now and again that
the official socialist Twitter handle
that's verified which I always think is
there was such a thing oh yeah you know
the Socialist Party of America is I mean
it's very okay and of course they're
using all the tools of capitalism to
promote the very same things about okay
fine but they you know people always say
we'll look at MIT as well as say well no
it's just never done right there their
argument is it was just never done right
yeah which perhaps says there's
something wrong with you yeah and I see
some of that in the kind of far extreme
libertarians it's sort of
anarcho-capitalists you know well we
don't really need government yeah well
what about all these oh oh that's just
not capitalism done right ok wait a
minute guys now we've had you know two
centuries here of the experiment in
America which is relatively free and
still you see why some you know steering
from the the government is good some
rules people will cheat if you don't
have rules just look at sports
yeah and I'm amazed they may cheat
either way but that doesn't mean there's
right that's right we need rules so you
know I get again just don't go don't go
to extremes are almost always a problem
and anyway so the chapters on utopia
isn't dystopias are addressing the
claims about what we can create heaven
on earth know again like when they like
the Ray Kurzweil say to me don't you
want to live to be a
you're Shermer listen just get me to 90
I don't have cancer give me no 100 where
I don't have Alzheimers I don't even
know who I am 110 where I'm not down a
morphine drip in a bed just you know
it's a little bit yeah and again you
know it's like let's just try to lower
the crime rates in Chicago this year
this is just one thing you know like we
know that you know if you park a squad
car at the corner of Pico and Sepulveda
you know the crime rate will go down
right there
okay just one little bit now to you know
to the average you know college student
that's not sexy I want I want to aim for
a thousand years from now we're gonna
have the perfect society right you mean
like the Third Reich you mean that kind
of you know right where it where it just
never gets it I guess is the inherited
problem with that though that when
Michael Shermer is 90 and let's say
they've done enough things and you've
tweaked it right so that you don't have
Alzheimer's in your bodies basically
okay but you know you're getting in
suddenly you are gonna keep wanting to
extend that course absolutely that's you
know surveys show that you know that
most people will say how long would you
like to live it's almost always right
around the average life the lifespan
that we have now you know about 80 85 90
seems about right now if you had asked
them 50 years ago Wow I'd be happy if I
make it a 65 and get my retirement you
know so but but this is easily refuted
if you were now 82 and we said would you
like to do tomorrow's today no no I need
another week okay then the week is that
would you like another month I'll take
another month you know now I'm not
talking about you're on a morphine drip
in a bed and you're out of it I'm
talking about just leaving normal
healthy life in your conscious and aware
and sharp and you know would you like
another year yeah yeah I'll take another
year yeah of course people would say
that once you get there now people are
thinking on me they're gonna be on in a
bed on a morphine drip or they're
thinking oh this is bad for society
there'll be too many people over a
population of people lived 150 years
they need to die you know like it's a
Soylent Green thing like we're gonna
turn him into food and you know it's
never them of course that's going to do
this it's always you know it's the same
thing with people you know
overpopulation well we need to get those
people are you gonna handle on birth
control and they can't have babies
you mean those people over there you
know the other ones that are not like us
you know okay no no good it's so
interesting this reminds me of my
grandma's cousin so I guess it's my
she's my first cousin twice removed I
suppose a barber she's 87 years old I
think maybe 88 lives in Manhattan
Manhattan born and bred her entire life
basically in Manhattan which is a really
unique type of thing
she's a piano teacher and I was talking
to her about life meaning a life all
this stuff about a year ago and she said
I just have so much more to do and I
just thought what a great what a great
thing for 87 days who's happy and laughs
and I don't have you know drinks with
her and she's standing on and vibrate
and all of that but I thought that's
really something I still have so much
more to do
right when most people are kind of
packing it up yeah or feeling around
well the research on that shows that
does does make a difference you know
again not to live 200 whatever just just
italy and back to the here and now just
to live a higher-quality more richer
life which we have the availability to
do so now not for a thousand years from
now just for tomorrow and next week next
year and so on and those kinds of things
being actively involved working out
exercising every day eating whole foods
I mean even even the diet stuff is you
know that's really hard to get you know
we know now at least a few things sugar
and you know starches processed
carbohydrates you know the fast foods
that stuff's not so good you know now it
turns up meat and eggs are back in yay
whole milk taking drink whole milk on my
cereal like I told you when you got here
I'm starting this Paleo diet
oh yes yogurt okay great I'm doing it's
a lot of butter and coconut oh yeah yeah
and that my temperaments been pretty
good yeah so far you're not falling
apart at all right but those are the
things you're saying basically take
control of the things you can in your
life to maximize you yes and in like
having lots of choices making decisions
like old people in what I call the sort
of homes lost my train of thought there
but you know these nursing homes yeah
the more the nurses do for them the
worse it is for the patient they really
need to be actively involved and get out
and move and just get the blood flowing
and decision making and so on is any of
those Studies on you know the nuns that
kept Diaries their whole life you know
they had lower rates of Alzheimer's
there's a few studies that show being
act mentally active
may help attenuate the plaques and
tangles that are associated with
Alzheimer's that research is a little
complicated and it's not as good as I
would like it you know if I just played
chess or did soduku puzzles everyday I
won't get I was like unfortunately we
can't really say that but right but I
think we can say Twitter is destroying
yes it's probably Twitter Alzheimer's
are both gobies
yes that may be one of those
correlations well listen tremor I think
we should well I have a feeling we're
gonna do this you know many times over
the course of many years in componentry
right certainly we should do it when
you're about 90 yes I see where I'm at
and then we'll go does he want a little
more time here I'll take two more Ruben
shows when I'm a hundred it's always an
absolute pleasure you're pretty much the
perfect guest and I want to get more
people to our quadrant of the political
thing because I think you've proven here
really perhaps proven but maybe in a
more broad sense you've Illustrated that
it's not just about that political part
there's something else right about how
to live or something yeah that puts us
maybe in that realignment that we're
always working on and that's really very
cool well what you're doing is talking
to people that's that's where it starts
what else can we do but talk and then
act what else can we do by doctor and
act all right heavens on earth we're
gonna link to it right down below and
you can follow Michael on the Twitter
machine which is not good for your
cognitive health or your sanity but if
you want to go for it it's at Michael
Shermer
[Music]
you